well y'all got a big reaction from the
big Premiere at can so how is that a
five-minute Standing Ovation and Lily
was this the first time that you had
watched it with an entire audience yeah
it was the first time that I had watched
it with an audience you know outside of
like myself and Sam and Ashley and Abel
which is how I kind of watched the first
couple episodes
um but it was incredible like it felt
like you know it felt like such a
beautiful celebration and like
culmination of of everything that we've
you know everything that we've been
through together and and just like kind
of uh yeah the beautiful process that
was making the show and and creating
this little family together and it just
felt really really nice and special to
get to celebrate together and we're just
so
um happy with the response from from the
room and everything it felt really nice
to to watch people react to it and
everything and finally get to share
something with the world that we that
we're all so proud of I'm worried she's
having another psychotic break it's a
lot it's a lot now I feel like when
audiences see this show they're gonna
make comparisons of this pop star
Jocelyn with none other than Britney
Spears who were you actually thinking of
when you were creating this woman in
this character Lillians of course
there's so many incredible pop stars of
today that I that I you know have
nothing but admiration and respect for
and of course that you can't help but
think of what you're thinking about my
character like Jocelyn but um I
definitely we're definitely not telling
anybody else's story or or trying to
um base her on any any real person and
we actually Drew from a lot of other
influences that are not pop stars like
you know we thought a lot about
um uh Sharon Stone in Basic Instinct and
you know the kind of Gene tierneys and
Lauren because of the world and general
and like all of these other women that
were very
um uh that were very inspiring to me for
for the role what year for trail is
incredible because even down to your run
and whenever you're filming the music
video it's like oh my God you've even
got the pop star rundown
girlfriends
and I just I guess I just couldn't I
couldn't quite step out of myself for
that one but thank you thank you very
much
you were literally a
Idol
[Music]
s
so did you give Lily any advice when it
came to performing as Jocelyn did you
give her any K-Pop Idol tips
I don't remember we did have this
conversation like long time ago when we
did not know that you were I was going
to be a part of the Idol with Lily we
talked about
the thing is
we did have the conversation but I don't
know what what which tip that I said
okay just like talking generally but I
mean like I I don't you know obviously
like I'm not a pop star I don't know
anything about this world and everything
so you know any kind of insight into
just like kind of you know just what
it's like to be in those shoes and
everything is always helpful and you
know who best to learn from but these
two I know right so were you watching
any like black pink performances Lily
Rose to get you in that mindset I
actually got to see a a black thing and
Jenny live not that long ago and it was
so much fun I had the best time ever you
and your blackpink inmates you guys are
always so supportive of one another you
actually sent jisu I believe like a
coffee truck and a bunch of gifts when
she was doing her kdrama so how did the
girl surprise you with anything or did
they surprise you with anything while
you were filming the idol so when I was
filming for the Idol last year it was
while we were filming the music video
for our latest albums warm pink so they
just checked in on me every day they
would call me when I was
um in L.A shooting just making sure that
I was doing all right on my own and like
today then she still texted me saying
you look beautiful I'm so happy for you
oh yeah it's like a nice family
that we have yeah oh it absolutely is
you guys bring it to us with all of your
music but I love hearing that you all
have that support behind the scenes as
well and Troy You Are bookended by two
just spectacular women
you're a lucky man I tell you when was
the last truly nasty nasty bad pop girl
tell me this how did you expect that La
Valley boy accent of yours
you know I'm playing a creative director
a gay creative director so for me it was
like oh I've like dated these people
before a million of them so you know I
know exactly where they live I know what
their bedroom looks like I know what
their bedroom smells like
so I was just pulling from from some
real life experiences oh my gosh
plenty plenty really well give me some
of this
hand dude give me a little taste of what
you can do show it off show us your
skills
you'll have to watch more of the shows
yeah yeah yeah watch episodes oh Troy
I can't I'm like I that was one of the
you know one of the biggest like
learning curves for me is
um I've never done improvisational
acting before and and a lot of what we
were doing on set was improvising and so
for me
um a big thing was
becoming comfortable enough to improvise
in my American accent and so I was like
you know doing it in like when I'm
ordering my coffee in the morning and
stuff like that just mortified trying to
practice my American accent as much as I
could you ever go back and forth into it
now
once I once I raped I was really happy
to say goodbye to that for a while I was
hoping I could hear it Troy I love it so
much you can watch it June four Lily
Rose your dad of course Johnny Depp he's
also at can this year and he received a
rousing standing ovation he had an
incredible reception so how happy were
you to see that reception that you
received and what do you think that
really meant to your father I'm super
happy for him I'm super excited and it's
you know it's so awesome that we both
get to be here with projects that we're
super proud of
[Music]
thank you